In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
Though reading, from the Sinaxadion, for June 28th, on which we commemorate, are venerable
and God-bearing fathers, surges and yermanos, hermen, founders of the monastery of Valaam.
Our Holy Father, surges, was said to be originally from the east and of Greek descent.
In Providence led him to the Karelia region in the far north, to spread the good news there.
He settled on the principal island of Lake Ladoga, at the place where according to tradition
the Apostle Andrew had once planted a cross.
He led there a strict ascetic life for nearly sixty years, exhausting his flesh with fasting
and vigils, but radiating the joy and peace of the Holy Spirit.
During the day, he would copy the Holy Scriptures and preach the Word of God to the people,
who asked in great numbers to receive holy baptism.
Little by little, a monastery began to grow on the site of the saint's retreat.
Surges guided them with great wisdom, spending his last years in a cave where he finally
gave his soul into God's hands in peace.
He was buried with great honors by one of the indigenous chiefs, whom he had baptized
with the name of Quarth, and who raised a great stone cross over his grave.
Saint Yermanos, who seems to have been one of his first disciples, or who may even have
come with surges from the east, became his successor.
His conduct was like that of his spiritual father in all things, both in ascetic labors
and in apostolic works, and because of this he was able to confirm and strengthen the monastery
that surges had founded.
When he died, he was buried next to Saint Surges on the site of Saint Andrew's cross, but
shortly after this, the monastery was exposed to nomadic raids, and the monks took their
relics to another place, and afterwards to Novgorit.
Once the relics had been brought back to the monastery, several attempts were made over
the course of the centuries to open their tomb, but a flame would shoot out from it, enveloping
the tomb.
On 1371, the king of Sweden and Norway, magnus II Ericsson, returning from a failed siege
of Novgorit, became the only survivor of a shipwreck of Valam.
Rescued by the monks, he realized that his life had been spared through the prayers of
Saint's surges and Yermanos, and paying heed to this sign of providence, he had himself
instructed in the Orthodox faith and exchanged the royal purple for the monastic habit.
Tonsured under the name of Gregory, he gave his soul into God's hands three days later.
These two holy fathers had received from God the gift of prophecy and insight, and they
poured out on all their disciples the munificence of divine grace.
After their deaths, they continued to protect the monastery and the inhabitants of the region
by their miracles, being particularly invoked as the protectors of sailors, and for the deliverance
of the possessed.
A vast monastic city developed around the synabetic monastery with many hermits and small semi-erimidical
communities so that the monastery of Valam could truly be called the Athos of the North.
Great numbers of holy fathers came from this monastic center, which was known for its austerity
and whose rule spread to many other Russian monasteries, Saint Abraham of Rastov, Arsinius
of Konevits, Savatius and Jermanus, the founders of Solovky, Alexander of Svir, and many others,
both known and unknown.
On the 20th of February in 1579, the monastery of Valam was completely destroyed by Scandinavian
Lutherans and 37 monks and 47 novices and laymen received the crown of martyrdom on that occasion.
It remained in ruins for more than two centuries before restoration work was begun on the orders
of Peter the Great.
The monastery experienced its greatest flowering at the end of the 18th century when Metropolitan
Gabriel sent St. St. Nazadius to the monastery of Satov in 1785.
Nazadius had a great church built, which was dedicated to the transfiguration, and he guided
numerous monks along the narrow way that leads to the kingdom of God by Askecies and the
Asidius use of the Jesus Prayer, according to the tradition restored by St. Paesius Belichkovsky.
St. Hermann of Alaska was one of the disciples of St. Nazadius and was sent by him to sow the seed
of Orthodox monasticism in the new world.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.